[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur LCP dans
savoure garde ce soir la journée presque
parfaite des insoumis à l'Assemblée le
groupe elle est fier a remporté une
victoire sur l'IVG sa première
proposition de loi sur le droit à
l'avortement dans la Constitution a été
largement adoptée grâce à un accord avec
la majorité et c'est une première
surprise la seconde proposition sur
l'interdiction de la corrida a été
retirée par Aymeric Caron face à
l'obstruction journée très riche en
rebondissements vous allez le voir sur
fond d'affaires cadenas qui secoue les
troupes la stratégie lfiant question
c'est notre grand débat ce soir notre
grand témoin tire un bilan sans
concession et souvent très drôle de sa
campagne éclaire à la présidentielle
dans un livre stimulant contre un aux
éditions de l'Observatoire il assume ses
paradoxes cette présentée à une élection
qu'il critique radicalement alors 60 ans
après faut-il en finir avec l'élection
du président au suffrage universel comme
il le propose Gaspard Koenig philosophe
et essayiste et maintenant politique
avec nous dans la deuxième partie enfin
deux affranchies ce soir Pierre-Henri
tavoyau du collège de philosophie le
mondial de foot théâtre universel sans
équivalent et puis un nouveau visage
qu'on est ravi d'accueillir Nicole
Ferroni aura désormais régulièrement une
carte blanche sur cette nouvelle
Assemblée voilà pour le mieux ce soir
c'est parti
[Musique]
c'est l'image du jour et elle est plutôt
rare des camps politiques que tout
oppose debout dans l'hémicycle pour
saluer l'adoption de la proposition de
loi insoumise sur l'IVG vous le voyez la
gauche de la nuesse le centre d'Emmanuel
Macron et quelques voix de droite et du
RN ensemble pour inscrire ce droit
fondamental dans la Constitution c'est
quasiment la première fois qu'un texte
émanent déléfique est adopté grâce aux
voies de la majorité présidentielle
alors évidemment le parti de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon à l'Assemblée n'a pas boudé
son plaisir
et brise en nos entraves debout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le on et le Off et ce qui s'est passé
dans l'hémicycle et puis beaucoup de
choses en coulisses c'était très
politique mais d'abord on va commencer
avec l'IVG Stéphane certains disent que
c'était un jour historique à l'Assemblée
si j'ai bien compris ce soir pour la
cause des femmes on dépasse les clivages
[Musique]
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir à toutes
bonsoir à tous allez si j'ai bien
compris sur l'IVG ce soir
une niche parlementaire c'est un petit
peu comme histoire de Cendrillon une
fois par an chaque groupe minoritaire
dispose d'une journée magique où il peut
décider des textes qui seront débattus
dans l'hémicycle mais attention c'est
comme dans Cendrillon je vous ai dit à
minuit pile le carrosse redevient
citrouille et tous les textes qu'on n'a
pas pu examiner allez hop à la trappe
donc aujourd'hui c'était le tour des
filles ils avaient déposé 12 textes qui
n'auraient pas le temps d'être débattu
mais ça leur donne une tribune pour
montrer ce qui les intéresse la Genèse
les outre-mer le pouvoir d'achat mais au
départ la priorité c'était de faire
voter un texte pour me lancer sur uber
ces liens avec l'Elysée bref
déstabiliser le président ça ils l'ont
finalement retiré comme ils ont retiré
le texte sur le SMIC de telle manière
que le premier texte qui a été
examiné c'est celui sur
l'ivgre pour essayer de le faire c'est
stratégies qu'on comprend c'est une
sorte de course contre la monde c'est
parlementaire alors au départ c'était
pas gagné non parce que vous dites c'est
une question de temps à la niche
parlementaire elle prend fin à minuit
pile donc le jeu des adversaires c'est
évidemment de déposer une quantité
innombrable d'amendements donc de gagner
du temps de reculer le moment et voilà
c'est comme ça qu'on espère ne pas
laisser le texte aboutir donc c'est pas
glorieux effectivement comme méthode
c'est ce qu'a fait Laurent saber mon
national et pour ça dépend ce qu'il a
dit bah c'est pas nous qu'on a commencé
on écoute quand on a voulu défendre le
pouvoir d'achat des Français au mois de
juillet qui nous a fait passer toute une
nuit sur les ports métaniers ce qui ne
faisait pas du tout avancer le pouvoir
d'achat des Français c'est la nupes
alors en termes de
cavalier en termes d'obstruction je
pense que vous êtes extrêmement mal
placé pour faire la leçon donc là les
insoumis sont exaspérés ils veulent
répondre à semblant national du coup on
perd encore plus de temps arrive Bruno
millienne sage qui dit écoutez ne tombez
pas dans le piège de rassemblement
national réfléchissez les amis en écoute
de grâce chers collègues vous allez
défendre vos amendements de ce côté-là
c'est très bien
ne répondez pas de l'autre côté ça ne
sert pas nos débats merci voilà on
laisse tomber les amendements hors
sujets du Front national on fait comme
s'il n'était pas là et c'est un peu ce
qui s'est passé donc le RN n'est demande
dépose des animaux hors sujet et puis le
gouvernement et le rapporteur font comme
si ça n'existait pas
nous proposons d'inscrire la
Constitution après l'article 3 que la
République ne reconnaît qu'une seule
communauté la communauté nationale
merci monsieur le député madame la
rapporteur très défavorable monsieur le
garde des sceaux monsieur le garde des
sceaux votre avis s'il vous plaît mais
alors totalement défavorable madame la
Président c'est drôle ces attelages qui
s'entendent bien c'est de là d'un coup
alors comment ça s'est débloqué c'est ça
la question tout simplement parce que
justement ils ont réussi les uns et les
autres nippess et majorité à dépasser ce
qui les oppose pour se concentrer sur
l'essentiel donc Erwan Balanant a joué
un rôle important là dedans chacun a dû
faire malgré tout des concessions donc
notamment du côté des insoumis qui sont
pas réputés non plus pour leur sens du
compromis ben là c'est Mathilde panot
qui a dit ok moi je voulais mettre la
contraception aussi dans la Constitution
j'y tiens beaucoup hein je le rappelle
que j'y tiens beaucoup mais j'y renonce
pas que ça vaut le coup on l'écoute
je rappelle que en Pologne lorsque le
droit à l'avortement est attaqué et bien
on sait aussi la pilule du lendemain
sans ordonnance qui est interdite donc
c'est je crois que ce sont deux
corollaires mais je préfère le retirer
pour éviter l'obstruction parlementaire
donc côté majoritaire on a fait un peu
déconcession on voulait donner le
sentiment de tirer trop la couverture
donc Aurore berger qui avait prévu un
texte semblable à son projet elle l'a
retiré aussi elle est même revenue à
l'Assemblée un peu plus tôt que prévu
considérant que c'était un moment
historique et ce qui lui a donné envie
de Ben d'évoquer comment les choses
avaient évolué et raconté un souvenir de
sa mère qui était qui avait bien
avortement avant que ça soit légalisé et
voilà comme on avait été accueilli à
l'époque à l'hôpital
et alors alors qu'elle était dans les
mains de médecins et bien ce qui s'est
passé à ce moment là c'est qu'elle a en
effet pu mettre un terme à sa grossesse
mais qu'elle a subi un curetage sans
anesthésie voilà ce qui se passait voilà
ce que les femmes subissaient voilà ce
que nos maires ont pu subir voilà ce que
nos grands-mères ont pu subir
donc voilà on comprend l'engagement de
leur berger qui a toujours été en pointe
sur cette question donc finalement c'est
ce que ça prouve c'est surtout qu'on a
réussi à trouver un accord autour de cet
amendement transpartisans pas uniquement
les filles et des FIA prouvé qu'ils
étaient capables de faire des compromis
la majorité elle a prouver qu'elle était
capable évidemment de réunir une vraie
majorité la maturité finalement
les Français on a cessé de le dire ici
ont d'ailleurs fait en sorte que nous
ayons une nouvelle assemblée et que nous
arrivions à démontrer que nous pouvions
travailler différemment c'est sur la
question des droits des femmes nous ne
sommes pas capables de le faire alors
nous serons capables de le faire sur
aucun texte donc il y a des 80% des
Français favorables à l'IVG dans la
Constitution les députés l'ont adopté en
revanche il y a 80% des Français qui
sont contre la corrida et ça ça n'a pas
été adopté on va en parler encore un peu
de sujets aujourd'hui merci beaucoup
très très complet très pédagogique et
toujours aussi enlevé merci Stéphane
Erwan Balan qu'est-ce qui s'est passé en
coul et quel rôle vous avez joué et
est-ce que depuis le début c'était la
stratégie enfin la volonté de la
majorité que de retirer votre texte qui
sensiblement été identique à celui des
insoumis on avait il faut il faut
reprendre rapidement l'histoire ça part
de la décision de la Cour suprême et au
moment américaine pardon et au moment de
la décision de la Cour suprême
américaine
simultanément
Mathilde panot pourrait LFI et Aurore
berger pour renaissance des pauses de
projets de loi constitutionnel
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
pour inscrire l'IVG dans la Constitution
donc on avait deux textes ça donnait
quelque part une chance aussi d'avoir
deux fois plus de chance de d'aboutir et
deux fois plus de temps de débats et on
a eu des commissions de commissions un
pour le texte de
Delphine panot et un pour le texte
Mathilde panot vous voyez je commençais
à être fatigué aussi de Mathilde panot
et de d'Aurore et moi j'avais senti
assez vite que pour une fois sur ce
sujet là on pouvait obtenir un consensus
on a déjà débattu sur ces questions là
et sur ces questions là visiblement il y
avait des des blocages de certains
groupes qui étaient prêts à faire de
l'opposition à faire de l'obstruction et
là j'ai vu très vite qu'il y avait la
possibilité de
comme ça on va voir son chef de groupe
on décide de prendre la plume on réécrit
sur un bout de table avec son adversaire
politique parce qu'on va pas avoir le
temps de faire tout le processus on
était un certain nombre à avoir
travaillé le sujet sur le mandat
précédent Marie-Pierre ricksain moi et
d'autres moi j'ai repris la copie qu'on
avait eu et j'ai amendé le texte de
Madame panot en commission en disant
voilà c'est une ouverture et je vous
propose qu'on travaille sur cette base
et cette base a été cette balle a été
prise au bon par Mathilde pano et par un
peu tout le monde et on a avancé
collectivement pour les femmes victoire
pour quoi le Parlement appeler quand
même qui sont à l'initiative ce sont
c'est une victoire la liste c'est la
niche des insoumis c'est très bien et
Mathilde panot a eu la sagesse de
d'accepter un certain nombre de
compromis aussi et il faut le dire et
c'est très bien mais c'est une victoire
vraiment collective et c'est une
victoire de la représentation nationale
bonsoir merci d'être là merci aussi la
majorité ce soir vous vous les remercier
la majorité présidentielle parce que
c'est aussi grave
tous les députés les collègues qui ont
été décisifs dans la fabrication de cet
accord
effectivement la la proposition de loi
d'Aurore berger était passé en
commission des lois avant d'ailleurs
celle de Mathilde panot et déjà la
droite avait présenté certains nombre
d'objections le modem également qui ce
jour-là n'ont pas été intégrés dans la
commission des lois roi berger était
resté assez campé sur sa version du
texte et aujourd'hui on sait ensuite en
commission d'aboutir on va pas refaire
le débat on l'a eu hier sur les végémies
c'est au fond ce qui se joue comme un
corps politique et c'est historique de
de se dire que vous pouvez mêler vos
voix ou vous assumez il y a rien de très
très original Myriam en cacahuète depuis
le 1er jour où on a mis les pieds ici il
y a eu un tas de fois où il y a eu des
majorités qui se sont faites d'ailleurs
ce qui m'étonne c'est qu'on continue de
faire comme si ça n'existait pas je
rappelle sur le plat la première
ministre a dit que il y avait un arc
républicain et que tout ça
a volé en éclat vous êtes d'accord avec
ça
n'a jamais existé en vrai sur le PLF on
a obtenu un tas de de votes qui sont des
votes majoritaires démocratiques par
exemple sur les 12 milliards pour la
rénovation thermique et combien d'autres
le fameux amendement Mattei combien on
en a énormément parlé sur la taxe sur
les super donc vous êtes tous très Sat
c'est une belle victoire de la
représentation nationale Catherine
tricot j'aurais que on puisse faire
parler tout le monde pour ce premier
tour de table oui il me semble quand
même c'est il y a un événement c'est que
c'est une proposition de loi de la
France insoumise c'est à dire que c'est
différent par rapport à des amendements
qui ont pu être voté avec la France
insoumise ça fait quand même une
distance quand même Catherine parce que
c'est un sujet sociétal évidemment
transpartisan transcrivage depuis le
début et pour pouvoir le mettre à
l'agenda tout en haut on a passé les
sujets sociaux à la trappe c'est à dire
le social le SMIC à 1600 la question de
l'ubérisation de la société à la trappe
pour pouvoir passer un sujet sociétal
est-ce que vous y voyez là un nouvelle
manière de trouver des accords sur le
sociétal à gauche et ce que je pense
c'est qu'il y avait une opportunité de
gagner quelque chose donc ça a été c'est
ça qui a été à mon avis déterminant dans
le choix de remonter ce sujet là en haut
de la pile parce que il y avait une
opportunité de gagner pourquoi il y
avait cette opportunité notamment parce
que je pense que la majorité relative le
groupe du président à l'Assemblée il est
quand même un peu embarrassé avec sa
gestion à coûte 49,3 ou il ne retient
pas des amendements qui malgré tout ont
été votés comme par exemple celui dont
on vient de parler même Garrido celui
sur la rénovation thermique donc du coup
il y a quand même l'idée qu'il y a un
peu d'autoritarisme dans sa dans la la
conduite du débat à l'Assemblée et la
gestion donc là ils ont eu l'opportunité
de dire ben non mais finalement on n'est
pas si sectaire que ça on n'est pas si
opposé à toute propositions
favorable depuis le début alors que le
président Macron pour allonger les
délais de 12 à 14 c'était plus compliqué
c'était avant son élection Adrien est-ce
que vous voyez là une une forme de voilà
de nouvelles manières de un peu de faire
de la politique dans cette assemblée là
sur des sujets sociétaux notamment
est-ce que c'est un cas isolé ou au
contraire on pourrait voir des des
mélanges de voix que on n'a pas
l'habitude de voir Adrien Mathoux
alors je serai positif moi je pense que
c'est peut-être une victoire tactique
pour la France insoumise qui a fait le
choix de présenter les textes qui
étaient susceptibles d'être acceptés par
la majorité ou qui pouvait comme pour la
Corrida divisé les autres forces
politiques mais je pense que
stratégiquement c'est moins
justifié parce que si le but de la
France insoumise et la gauche en général
et d'élargir son audience et de montrer
qu'elle ne parle pas
qu'au je caricature pour aller plus vite
bobo des centres-villes et au banlieue
il fallait peut-être mettre en avant des
thèmes sociaux alors là j'ai peut-être
vous choquer mais on a fait semblant de
penser que l'IVG était menacé en France
ce qui est un petit peu lunaire parce
que vous l'avez dit vous-même on a on a
pris
on a pris pour déclencher la discussion
un événement américain pour les insoumis
arracher une victoire dans l'hémicycle
aujourd'hui c'est presque plus important
que de parler à son camp sont délectorat
ils ont parlé une partie de leur lecteur
mais là vous parlez du social des gens
qui votent déjà pour eux et
c'est un peu lunaire quand même on parle
de la Pologne à la tribune on parle on
s'inspire des États-Unis je suis pas en
train de vous dire que il faut revenir
sur l'IVG pas du tout ce que je vous dis
c'est que on crée une espèce de menace
artificielle on allait parler de la
corrida finalement on le fait pas mais
est-ce qu'on parle vraiment des sujets
qui ont un impact sur la vie des gens je
pense que les femmes c'est une grande
avancée et
les femmes tout en France de cette
avancée
on a ça fait très longtemps qu'on porte
l'idée de constitutionnaliser l'IVG
puisqu'on est pour une 6e avant
on a un tas de propositions de révision
constitutionnelle et de nouvelles
libertés qu'il faut intégrer le droit de
mourir dans la dignité par exemple on a
toujours porté ce sujet là et on l'a
gagné et aussi ça ça correspond à une
certaine comment dire à un nouveau
protagonisme de l'Assemblée nationale
dans l'architecture institutionnelle de
la Cinquième République qui
traditionnellement et écrasée par le
poids du château et de l'exécutif et ce
qui se passe et c'est très intéressant
sur le plan démocratique c'est que
l'assemblée se rebiffe et l'assemblée
tout entière et là dessus 100% d'accord
avec ça dire tout entière dit mais la
loi ça se passe ici la loi c'est nous
Erwan Balan
à replacer dans le contexte c'est aussi
parce que
notre groupe prend décide d'aller vers
Delphine panot et de leur dire
mais je sais pas ce que j'ai excusez-moi
Mathilde panot c'est peut-être parce
qu'on a passé beaucoup de temps ensemble
et je suis un peu perdu ça nous ça ne
change nos habitudes et c'était un très
bon moment
Mathilde panot on va la voir et on offre
nous le groupe modem on a fait on a
tendu la main et on a attendu la main
pourquoi parce qu'il y a un enjeu et je
suis pas du tout d'accord avec vous sur
le fait que c'est pas un enjeu du moment
que c'est pas non plus important il y a
une menace on ne sait jamais ce qui peut
se passer et surtout c'est de notre
responsabilité quand vous détendre
c'est dommage
c'est de notre responsabilité de
législateur on est représentant d'une de
la nation et à certains moments de
sortir un peu de la nasse et sortir de
la politique politicienne pour avancer
sur des sujets
c'est un moment historique historique
parce que on a été collectivement on a
été capable collectivement d'écrire un
bout de la Constitution en faisant fi de
nos différences et de nos convergence
parce que en réalité on a un arc je sais
pas comment on peut l'appeler de la
nuque jusqu'à au Modem et une partie des
républicains qui voulaient
oui on est qui voulait c'est pas le
sujet pour moi qui voulais acheter
évidemment mais oui la réponse est oui
ce principe dans la Constitution et
c'était pas simple à faire on l'a vu les
les c'est pas fini c'est pas
complètement terminé
qu'on apporte au Sénat c'est de leur
dire vous voyez nous sommes largement
majoritaire et par rapport au Sénat qui
est la représentation des territoires
nous nous sommes la représentation
nationale c'est dit alors moi je
voudrais quand même qu'on prenne un peu
d'auteur parce qu'il y a pas mal de
propositions doigts Stéphanie Despierres
c'est intéressant on l'a bien compris
ces stratégies hein ces fameuses niches
parlementaires pour les groupes et
notamment pour les groupes d'opposition
elles sont redoutées ces niches LFI par
la majorité il faut dire qu'il y a un
certain savoir-faire en la matière non
du côté des insoumis
oui depuis l'arrivée à l'assemblée des
insoumis en 2017 ils sont passés maître
dans l'art de faire ou de tenter de
faire des coups politiques lors de leur
journée à d'initiatives parlementaires
alors en 2017 ils étaient 17 aujourd'hui
ils sont 75 donc c'est encore plus vrai
et des 2021 le patron des macronistes
Christophe Castaner expliquer que les
niches parlementaires étaient des pièges
à con et les cons c'est nous un accès à
de lucidité tout à fait vérifiée encore
aujourd'hui on l'a vu depuis plusieurs
semaines les insoumis faisaient beaucoup
de communication autour de leur projet
de loi et puis ils avaient suivi ils
avaient choisi des thèmes très clivants
notamment la corrida et là c'était aussi
parce qu'il savait qu'au sein du groupe
renaissance du camp présidentiel tous
les députés n'étaient pas d'accord ça
permettait donc de faire passer une
partie du camp présidentiel pour
conservateur et puis ça permettait
d'enfoncer un coin comme on dit en sport
entre des députés du camp présidentiel
favorable à cette interdiction de la
corrida et d'autres députés défavorables
et depuis est-ce que la toujours été
justement c'est peut-être ce qu'on voit
ce soir à appris on a vu les insoumis
dénoncer l'obstruction c'est c'était un
peu l'arroseur arrosé également
oui l'obstruction venait surtout des
bons de des républicains et du
rassemblement national sur les
différentes propositions de loi mais en
effet les insoumis ont défendu cette
obstruction ils l'ont justifié ils ont
justifié derrière le retrait de leur
propositions loi sur la corrida par
cette obstruction en disant de toute
façon il aurait fallu 24 heures pour
faire le débat nous retirons notre
proposition de loi car c'est insuffisant
je vous le rappelle ils n'ont que
jusqu'à minuit ce soir pour débattre
donc ils ont et ils ont appris
c'est-à-dire qu'ils sont dans une
stratégie différente ils ont abandonné
un sujet clivant pour privilégier l'IVG
pour laisser de la place au débat sur
l'IVG thème qui faisait beaucoup plus
consensus puisque on l'a vu vous l'avez
dit la majorité présidentielle la
majorité relative à voter cette
proposition de loi des insoumise alors
certes réécrit en partie par un député
MoDem mais Renaissance la beauté et elle
a pu être adopté aujourd'hui donc on
voit un certain changement deux
stratégies des insoumis au fil de cette
journée au fil de la semaine parce qu'à
au lieu de prendre leur texte les plus
clivant ils ont choisi ceux qui
faisaient consensus et ceux qui avaient
une chance d'être adopté et c'est encore
le cas ce soir sur la proposition de
l'un sur la réintégration des soignants
qui est en discussion seulement on va
parler merci merci beaucoup Stéphanie
Despierre aimerait Caron est-ce qu'on
lui a forcé la main veut retirer son
texte on va l'écouter parce qu'il était
assez colère quand même quand il
explique que finalement il y aura pas de
débat il sera à la trappe la corrida à
écouter
est-ce qu'on a le son d'aimerait une
Caron sous la main de l'acheter chez
certains d'entre vous s'il
[Applaudissements]
dans la manière que vous avez
de tout faire pour refuser le vote le
vote qui vous donnerait tort
dans votre manière de tout faire pour
pas donner satisfaction 87 % de trophées
qui aujourd'hui réclame la police de la
corrida en France
vous avez compris pour aujourd'hui
malheureusement je suis contraint
contraint de retirer ce texte
[Applaudissements]
quatrième tricot oui enfin moi je pense
que on peut contraindre
moi je crois que c'est légèrement
exagéré de dire que 87% des Français
réclament le retrait de la corrida je
pense que 90% des Français s'en fichent
complètement franchement justement moi
très sérieusement ce que je pense c'est
qu'il y avait il y a des enjeux par
exemple la question de IVG est un enjeu
national la question de la corrida est
une question qui est-ce qui va avoir une
position
dans ce débat il est il vient de des
médias c'est un débat sur la corrida qui
a saturé les deux dernières semaines
dans dans la presse est-ce que il y a eu
un débat insoumis pour se dire attention
les Français il faut pas qu'ils
entendent ce message que la corrida
c'est leur préoccupations première pas
du tout
le rayonnement qui a eu ce débat dans le
pays et entièrement à mettre à l'actif
d'Aymeric Caron et des autres d'ailleurs
collègues insoumis qui sont à l'origine
de cette proposition de loi alors au
départ vous lui avez demandé de retirer
son son texte parce que avec 4 10
amendements il n'y avait aucune chance
de passer il fallait 24 heures pour
traiter tous les amendements donc après
c'est une question très concrète on est
quand même
bien sûr qu'il le prend mal mais il
situe il va comment dire c'est la faute
à ceux qui ont déposé ses amendements et
d'ailleurs il leur a demandé les retirer
je voudrais quand même dire que c'est
tout à fait faux de renvoyer la balle de
l'obstruction vers les insoumis en
disant vous l'avez déjà fait c'est tout
à fait faux d'abord c'est très rare que
les insoumis façons on l'a fait par
exemple sur la bataille des retraites et
mais par exemple depuis le début de
cette mandature on ne l'a pas fait et
surtout nous nous le faisons dans les
dans le cadre ou c'est l'exécutif qui a
la main et qui a tout son temps pour
faire la loi de nous ici comme le disait
c'est un blackovski c'est la carotte qui
devient citrouille à minuit donc c'est
ça le contexte on est quand même
d'ailleurs malgré ce que je disais tout
à l'heure
on est quand même pardon et juste je
voudrais terminer là-dessus c'est
important j'ai pas beaucoup parlé
la Cinquième République musel
l'Assemblée nationale le fait qu'on est
une journée par année une journée par
année où on a le droit de décider de
l'ordre du jour est un problème
démocratique en soi donc déjà qu'on est
bâillonné par le 49.3 à too bout de
champ si les députés eux-mêmes lorsque
voilà exceptionnellement ils ont le
pouvoir se commence à symbolir la
possibilité eux-mêmes de pouvoir mener à
bien leurs débat alors à ce moment-là
l'exécutif et les châteaux et l'Élysée
se frotte les mains puisque ça veut dire
qu'on se bâillonne nous-même les députés
c'est pas possible Erwan Balan on voit
quand même que sur ces deux textes il y
a eu d'ailleurs issu du même des mêmes
bancs il y a eu deux façons de faire de
la politique il y a eu la façon un peu
spectacle sur la corrida et puis une
façon un peu plus sérieuse une façon sur
le fond avec une vraie réflexion un vrai
travail vraiment
vous le savez avec une seule fois parce
que vous racontez n'importe quoi là
aymeric Caron
va voir l'ensemble des groupes travail
sur ce sujet et est dans une réflexion
avec une recherche de compromis Aymeric
Emeric Caron est parti sur un principe
d'abolition sèche de la corrida moi
j'aime pas la corrida et j'aurais sans
doute voté son texte si on avait pu
aller au bout donc ne me faites pas de
place mais sauf que ça c'est pas des
bonnes manières de faire il a invectiver
tout le monde il a dans dans la
commission
de barbares il n'a pas été personnel
j'aimerais juste dire quand même que on
a beaucoup parlé de la nouvelle méthode
et tout ça mais la nouvelle méthode il
faut aussi que chacun fasse un chemin
vers l'autre Mathilde pano a fait un
chemin nous avons fait un chemin nous
avons réussi à aboutir c'est l'exemple
qu'on peut le faire mais pour le faire
il faut arrêter ce que vous venez de
faire madame Garrido de couper de
de dire que voilà c'est très clair par
exemple c'est inadmissible
aimerait 40 n'est pas un insoumis de la
première heure c'est une évidence il y a
une greffe est-ce qu'elle a prise est-ce
que il y a des questions en interne sur
justement sa capacité à apprendre à
prendre la lumière sur un sujet qui
n'est pas forcément la première
préoccupation des Français ceci dit
retenir la corrida comme les les sujets
prioritaires de la niche c'était une
manière de lui donner de la confiance et
de dire qu'on lui qu'on le mettait en
avant après moi je ça rejoins un petit
peu ce que je disais tout à l'heure
c'est à dire que il y a un risque quand
même ce qui est de donner l'impression
aux Français que la France insoumise
vous l'avez dire à quel vous avez une
journée sur 365 jours par an et
qu'est-ce qu'on décide de mettre en
avant la corrida un sujet vous allez
trouver trop binaire les propositions
insoumises pour ou contre la corrida
pour ou contre le veget dans la
conception
il y a des sujets la société qui sont
importants il y a des sujets qui sont
clivants c'est pas la même chose la
corrida c'est un sujet qui est clivant
mais qui n'est pas centrale la question
du rapport entre Homo sapiens sapiens et
le reste du monde vivant n'est pas une
question annexe à l'échelle de
l'histoire de l'humanité aux gens tous
les jours vous êtes convaincu que de
toute façon on parle pas au peuple
populaire etc et c'est votre thèse vous
êtes dedans vous avez écrit la chute
vous avez dit qu'en 2022 Mélenchon allez
s'écouler il a juste fait 22 % donc là
en l'occurrence moi
entre nature et culture on l'a même eu
sur ce bateau pour les insoumis
d'enlever le SMIC précisément quelque
chose d'identitaire sur lequel tous les
Français savent que on le se balade
dessus depuis le premier jour qu'on est
rentré ici contre l'extrême droite et
contre la majorité présidentielle enfin
la minorité présidentielle qui s'oppose
à la hausse du SMIC d'accord bon mais
reconnaissez avec moi que le rayonnement
qui a pris pardon le rayonnement qui a
pris le débat sur la corrida dans la
société
pardon non je suis pas d'accord avec du
coup je ne fais pas la même analyse que
vous moi je pense vous mettra pas
d'accord sur la question de la corridaro
et les autres collègues et les aussi les
militants anticorida enfin je veux dire
tous les militants de la cause animale
dans ce pays etc apporter et a fait
avancer le débat et maintenant tous ceux
qui regrettent quand on n'est pas pu
aller jusqu'au bout de ce débat les
députés sont invités à signer une
proposition de loi transpartisane et ce
qui n'est pas marcher aujourd'hui
marchera la fois d'après
on termine ce débat parce qu'il y a
quand même une autre actualité qui
percute cette journée des insoumis c'est
l'affaire cadenas on va en parler dans
un instant mais maintenant ce soir dans
l'hémicycle et bien c'est la proposition
de loi pour réintégrer les soignants à
l'hôpital qui est discuté et là s'il y a
accord alors on est absolument pas
certain ce serait avec le rassemblement
national tout ça est cohérent pour vous
je dois dire que je suis les soignant
non vacciné bien sûr moi ça me enfin moi
je ne partage pas cette avis je trouve
que il y a un problème de principe que
les soignants respectent les obligations
et que je trouve ça étrange que la
France insoumise et là aussi porter
cette proposition de loi qu'elle est
mise en avant c'est-à-dire que je ne
vois ce qui cherche des accords
d'identification et que là il y a une
crise passion dans la société et qu'on
peut comprendre je comprends que il y a
15000 soignants qui ont et donc ça fait
une crispation un abcès de fixation et
que donc la France insoumise porte cette
question mais je moi je trouve ça
étrange que la France insoumise se
s'identifie à la question de du refus de
la vaccination pour les soignants parce
que je trouve que c'est c'est ça la met
c'est là encore dans des dans des
corners qui divisent ça divise à gauche
la corrida ça divise en France et je
pense que
majoritairement les Français sont pour
l'abolition de la corrida mais je pense
vraiment que très largement ce n'est pas
leur question par contre il y a beaucoup
d'autres questions en effet la question
de la collusion de Macron avec Hubert ça
c'était une vraie question la question
du SMIC était une vraie question la
question de la concentration dans les
médias était vrai question et ces
questions-là elles elles n'ont pas été
parce que voilà c'est c'est
interrogation elle traverse aussi la
gauche et pas simplement je pense que
c'est là où effectivement comme vous le
releviez au début de démission la France
insoumise montre aussi une certaine
habileté la France insoumise c'est un
groupe qui aspire à proie a exercé le
pouvoir dans ce pays on n'est pas à
l'Assemblée nationale par effraction on
sait aussi travailler dans un contexte
institutionnel qu'on cherche à faire
évoluer au bénéfice de l'assemblée et
effectivement la réintégration des
soignants non vaccinés c'est dans le
programme l'avenir en commun c'est dans
le programme de Mélenchon nous sommes
absolument pour que les soignants
respectent les protocoles et les règles
en revanche Caroline Fiat dans sa
proposition mais en place un protocole
il nous reste qui protège les soignants
les patients il nous reste quelques
temps permet de réintégrer les quelques
il y a beaucoup de sujets
vraiment les enjeux politiques qui se
voilà qui se trame derrière c'est très
stratégique c'est niche insoumise cette
journée presque parfaite pour les
insoumis a été quand même percuté par
l'affaire cadenas qui s'est invité dans
l'hémicycle pour pour ce pour tous ces
débats regardez
ce combat ne souffre aucune
compromission et mes chers collègues de
LFI c'est pourtant ce que vous faites en
soutenant et on t'aimant Adrien cattenin
la France insoumise attaquée par la
majorité présidentielle qui exploite
l'affaire Adrien catenin 24 heures après
le communiqué de son épouse en plein
divorce elle formule de nouvelles
accusations de violence contre le député
du Nord ça fait plusieurs années que je
subis ses colères ses crises des
violences physiques et morales une
déclaration jugée mensongère par Adrien
catenens aucun fait de violence répétée
ni de harcèlement ont été retenus par le
parquet jusqu'ici l'élu de la France
insoumise avaient reconnu une gifle dans
un contexte d'agressivité mutuelle il
est convoqué par la justice pour une
procédure de plaid découpable mais les
nouvelles accusations replonge la France
insoumise dans l'embarras et cette fois
Jean-Luc Mélenchon reste silencieux lui
qui diviser mi-septembre au sein même de
ces troupes proche d'Hadrien catenin
s'il avait défendu le député saluant son
courage et sa dignité pour avoir reconnu
la gifle contre sa femme Adrien Catena
c'est un des éléments les plus brillants
qui se soit imposés dans la dernière
période il a le droit non pas à la
violence bien sûr que non et ce n'est
pas un violent parce qu'il a été violent
une fois en retrait de sa fonction de
député depuis deux mois la France
insoumise réfléchissait ouvertement ces
derniers jours au retour d'Adrien
catenin salssemblée un retour jugé
impossible aujourd'hui par plusieurs
figures de la nupesse
on peut pas dans ces conditions revenir
sur les moments à l'Assemblée la justice
n'est pas passé ça s'est au moins le
minimum et je pense même que après se
pose la question de la représentation du
peuple et face à la pression politique
il se retrouve isolé dans son propre
camp Adrien cadenas ne participera pas
aux activités du groupe parlementaire le
temps de la décision judiciaire voilà je
n'ai rien d'autre à dire que cela
l'avenir politique d'Adrien catenens est
plus que jamais compromis il était
pourtant l'un des favoris à la
succession de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
Raquel Garrido
sans langue de bois c'est quand même un
vrai un vrai malaise qui traverse votre
groupe aujourd'hui avec cette affaire
l'ambiance conjugales c'est un malaise
qui traverse toute la société qui est
systémique et qui effectivement
n'épargne aucun parti aucun mouvement
aucune entreprise aucune famille et
évidemment c'est ça le sujet
j'insiste sur le fait que ce qui était
très important dès le départ c'était de
d'écouter Céline catenens de dire que sa
parole était entendue que du coup Adrien
catenens n'était plus coordinateur du
mouvement que du coup il était mis en
retrait du groupe parlementaire à partir
du moment où il y avait une procédure
judiciaire qui était démarrée c'est
évident qu'il fallait en attendre
l'aboutissement il y avait un bruit sur
le prétendu retour rapide imminent de
d'Adrien cadenas au groupe c'est vrai ça
fait quatre semaines que tout le monde
me dit ça dans les médias au groupe
parlementaires il n'a jamais jamais été
question d'un retour rapide d'Adrien
catenens et les faits récents c'est à
dire les communiquées de part et d'autre
qui sont des préliminaires en fait à la
au traitement judiciaire à
l'aboutissement du traitement judiciaire
confirme le fait un qu'il faut
effectivement attendre la fin de la
procédure pénale et deuxièmement que
nous avions raison de mettre en retrait
Adrien catenens du groupe le communiqué
a pris du temps quand même mais
maintenant la ligne elle est
suffisamment claire pour vous Adrien
matou ça tombe de choc elle va continuer
à irradier le parti mais moi je pense ça
concerne pas seulement la France
insoumise la France insoumise et
confrontée maintenant le problème c'est
qu'il y a deux postures qui est mon avis
sont un peu des impasses vous avez la
posture qui dit seulement on écoute la
justice mais vu les délais de traitement
de la justice et vu la difficulté de
prouver un viol ou une agression
sexuelle c'est très compliqué à tenir
comme position la position l'extrême
inverse un petit peu c'est de dire on
écoute la parole victime pas toujours
une bonne solution regardez le 4 Julien
Baillot par exemple et là par exemple
dans un cas comme celui de Adam 14
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ça son ex-femme
fait un communiqué pour dire qu'il y a
eu des violences physiques et morales
lui dit que c'est pas le cas qu'est-ce
qu'on fait compliqué
voilà c'est un sujet sur lesquels tous
les partis
se retrouvent face à une ambiguïté je
finis juste avec le problème de la
France insoumise c'est qu'on a
l'impression qu'il y a un contraste
entre
le féminisme très revendiqué et très
ferme à l'extérieur et le soupçon qui
existe sur le fait que ce féminisme est
beaucoup moins affirmé quand il concerne
des gens qui sont à l'intérieur du
mouvement et je pense que les séquences
avec 94 nains elles entretiennent un
petit peu ce doute on se dit bah est-ce
qu'ils sont pas en train quand même
certains d'essayer de protéger coûte que
coûte rien de faire en sorte qu'il
revienne
ce dossier un tout petit mot mais
vraiment le mot de la fin quelques
secondes moi ce que je pense c'est que
tous les partis doivent réfléchir à leur
gestion parce que ce n'est pas que la
justice ils ont une responsabilité
particulière parce qu'il y a de de
mettre en adéquation leur projet et leur
gestion et ça il faut mettre en place
des commissions et il y a des
associations féministes qui ont réfléchi
sur le sujet ont peut-être qu'on pourra
en discuter avec elle et c'est un long
chemin encore à parcourir on va terminer
ce débat je vous remercie avec des
nouvelles de l'hémicycle Stéphanie
Despierre vous avez quelques
informations concernant la séance qui a
été suspendue qui va reprendre sur la
proposition de loi sur les soignants non
vaccinés
alors c'est la pause dînée mais les
débats sont assez intenses bien que les
mystiques se soient beaucoup vidé par
rapport à cette après-midi la
proposition de loi des insoumis pour
réintégrer les soignants pourrait être
adoptés car ils bénéficie du soutien des
députés du rassemblement national d'une
majorité des députés les républicains de
quelques députés associalistes également
la majorité est pourtant très opposé à
cette proposition de loi mais les
députés Renaissance modem horizon ne
sont pas assez nombreux dans l'hémicycle
pour faire contrepoids et puis
mathématiquement à partir du moment où
il y a les insoumis leur Assemblée
nationale les LR qui votent et bien ils
seront battus alors ils cherchent une
stratégie pour jouer la montre ils sont
en train de déposer de très nombreux
sous amendements pour ralentir les
débats mais a priori ça ne suffira pas
pour contrer la proposition de loi à des
insoumis qui pourraient être adoptés ce
soir merci beaucoup Stéphanie Despierre
depuis la salle des quatre colonnes il
nous a rejoint en plateau Gaspard Kenny
bonsoir On va passer à votre livre
contraint vos volets en finir avec
l'élection présidentielle et l'élection
au suffrage universel on a pas mal de
questions à vous poser vous l'ancien
candidat malheureux éphémère à la
présidentielle candidat aussi paradoxal
vous assumez un certain nombre de
contradictions on voit ça tout de suite
après le l'invitation signé ce soir par
Marion Becker
[Musique]
si on vous invite Gaspard kennig c'est
pour votre dernière ouvrage contraint un
titre clin d'oeil à l'écrivain Étienne
de la Boétie et à son célèbre discours
de la servitude volontaire
rebaptisée contraint dans lequel le
poète est juriste s'étonne que les
hommes puissent obéir à un ne leur
semblable cet étonnement vous le
partagez l'exercice du pouvoir elle est
surtout trop personnel
depuis 62 le président de la République
est élu au suffrage universel ensuite le
passage au quinquennat la version des
calendriers
les changements constitutionnels ont
fait que le président a toujours plus de
pouvoir et le Parlement toujours moins
de contre-pouvoir
et donc on s'attend encore et toujours
ce qui paraît juste incroyable au 21e
siècle qu'un homme prenne seule
l'ensemble des décisions vous allez même
jusqu'à remettre
en couple
les universel une élection à laquelle
vous vous êtes vous-même présenté je me
suis dit qu'est-ce qu'on fait quand on a
des idées en démocratie et bah en font
la partie et aujourd'hui j'ai décidé
d'aller jusqu'au bout de cette démarche
et donc de me présenter à l'élection
présidentielle puisque c'est le moment
où peuvent émerger des forces politiques
nouvelles en France car gaspark koenig
vous êtes non seulement philosophe
romancier et essayiste mais aussi un
homme politique avec votre partie simple
dont le manifeste est votre avant
dernier ouvrage simplifions-nous la vie
dans lequel vous appeliez un allègement
des normes qui régissent nos vies dans
contraint vous raconter votre campagne
électorale pour en tirer une leçon de
philosophie sur notre régime politique
une critique de la personnalisation du
mythe de l'omniscience du candidat ce
présidentialisme exacerbait depuis le
général de Gaulle cette cinquième
République et son monarque Républic ce
coup d'état permanent pour reprendre la
célèbre formule de François Mitterrand
voulait combattez nous ne voulons plus
de ces demi-dieu mal luné écrivez-vous
au fil des pages vous esquissez une
autre vision de la société moins
verticale et plus participative un mode
de gouvernance radicalement différent
qui ne se contentent pas de choisir un
maître alors on vous pose la question
Gaspard Koenig n'est-ce pas
utopiste elle les Français sont-ils
vraiment prêts à un tel changement
c'est vrai ça Gaspard Koenig les
Français sont très attachés à cette
élection il y a qu'à voir toutes les
récentes enquêtes ça reste la grande
élection maîtresse dans leur cœur vous
croyez vraiment que c'est envisageable
pour eux d'en finir avec le suffrage
universel le choix de leur président je
pense en effet que c'est complètement
utopiste et qu'on est loin de voir un
président qui va s'aborer son propre
pouvoir mais en revanche je pense que
les Français ils seraient favorables
d'ailleurs nous avions fait un sondage
avec l'Ifop pour la sortie du livre et à
la question souhaitez-vous remplacer
l'élection présidentielle par des formes
de démocratiques plus participative des
Français répondaient à 60% oui de même
qu'en 1962 quand de Gaulle a fait le
référendum sur l'élection présidentielle
au suffrage universel il n'y a qu'une
minorité du corps électoral qui a dit
oui beaucoup d'abstention et seulement
62% au final donc en fait c'est un sujet
qui a toujours
une large majorité
et on voit qu'en fait c'est un sujet qui
a toujours perturbé les Français dans
l'histoire de Gaulle le dit dans ses
mémoires il explique qu'il avait cette
idée depuis 20 ans mais qui le faisait
pas parce qu'il savait très bien que les
Français avaient le souvenir de Louis
Napoléon Bonaparte qui vous souvenez en
1851 président de la République premier
président élu au suffrage universel sous
la deuxième république Tocqueville à ce
moment-là critiqué déjà l'élection
présidentielle universelle fait un coup
d'État et que à juste titre d'ailleurs
les Français associent l'élection
présidentielle à ce système très
plébiscitaire très bonapartiste et
qu'ils aspirent à quelque chose je pense
de beaucoup plus responsabiliser
le général de Gaulle je vous propose de
l'écouter c'était en 62 justement
lorsqu'il soumet par référendum la
possibilité pour les Français délire au
suffrage universel leur président écouté
suivant la Constitution le président est
en effet garant vous entendez bien
garant
de l'indépendance et de l'intégrité du
pays
ainsi que des traités qui langage bref
il répond de la France
pour que le président
puisse porter exercer effectivement
une charge pareille
il lui faut
la confiance
explicite de la nation
les modes de Gaulle c'est très
intéressant parce que dans le livre vous
le citez de nombreuses reprises vous
dites merci de nous avoir sauvé et
maintenant laissez-nous un peu
tranquille il faut qu'on réfléchisse à
un nouveau mode de gouvernement mais
franchement
il est voilà il dit tout de la fonction
aujourd'hui de la cinquième ce qui est
très intéressant c'est que quand on lit
ses discours dans le détail on
s'aperçoit qu'il fait pas ça pour lui
parce qu'il dit moi j'ai la légitimité
que me donne l'histoire et même si je
suis élu à l'époque en 58 au suffrage
indirect
néanmoins j'exerce des facto tous les
pouvoirs j'incarne et je représente la
nation et donc il fait ça après
l'attentat du Petit Clamart pour ses
successeurs disant je ne serai pas
éternel mais successeurs vont forcément
être des hommes politiques plus
médiocres qui n'auront pas été n'auront
pas reçu l'onction de l'histoire et donc
il faut trouver un moyen
mais la question c'est pourquoi faire ça
et bien et il le dit un peu son discours
parce qu'il faut que un homme un la
nation et ça suppose d'avoir une vision
extrêmement homogène extrêmement
unitaire de la nation il y a un homme et
il y a un peuple d'ailleurs de Gaulle le
dit souvent dans ses mémoires il parle
des Français il dit si vous imaginiez
combien vous vous ressemblez tous et pas
du tout votre conception
démocratique qui est un homme et un
peuple et puis il y en a une autre qui
est en fait beaucoup plus démocratique
et beaucoup plus fidèle à la définition
de la démocratie qui sont des citoyens
qui délibèrent pour se donner des lois
et pas pour se choisir un mètre et le
fameux contre 1 de ce titre qu'il faut
nous expliquer emprunter à La Boétie en
1576 deux livres sont publiés Jean Bodin
les six livres de la République qui
définit la notion de souveraineté et qui
dit la souveraineté doit être une et
préférablement elle doit être incarnée
et c'est finalement ce que de Gaulle
reflète et puis il y a la même année
Étienne la de la Boétie qui écrit le
discours de la servitude volontaire
sous-titré contraint et qui en deux mots
et qui dit peu importe
si le président est élu si le maître
vient simplement de l'histoire ou si
on est dans un système monarchique on ne
doit jamais obéir à un de ses semblables
les êtres humains sont égaux ils sont
faits pour s'entendre entre eux pour se
donner leur propre loi et pas pour se
choisir un mètre il y a quelque chose le
discours du libéral que vous êtes
libéral politique philosophique en même
temps dira exactement la même chose et
puis un Mendès France pour le Parti
radical dira la même chose il y a une
longue tradition démocratique derrière
cette idée que la démocratie doit être
avant tout représentative
n'est que l'élu de Dieu un vrai roi au
sens absolutiste du terme tandis que le
président français c'est Dieu lui-même
alors vous avez tous les mots en contre
la fonction présidentielle
omnie présente
omnisciente
omnipotente qu'est-ce que vous proposez
on revient à un régime parlementaire on
voit même qu'aujourd'hui quand même vous
êtes sévère ça se passe beaucoup à
l'Assemblée nationale les recompositions
aujourd'hui même un texte a été à
l'initiative des députés d'ailleurs je
salue cette nouvelle assemblée qui que
j'ai toujours trouvé très intérêt que
j'ai trouvé très intéressant depuis le
début et on voit qu'effectivement
certains compromis sont possibles mais
le problème c'est qu'on a toujours cette
horizon de l'élection présidentielle et
que donc on voit bien que les groupes
peuvent s'allier de temps en temps de
manière circonstancielle mais ont du mal
à former de véritables coalition parce
que dans leur esprit ils sont pas
vraiment là pour gouverner ils sont là
pour gagner à la prochaine le retour à
un régime
parable avec des
maladies de la République française deux
grands partis quels pouvoirs ont été
anniés par la Cinquième République
c'était d'ailleurs bien l'intention de
Gaulle et aujourd'hui vous voyez bien
que les gens qui se présentent sont des
gens qui se présentent en leur nom et
qui créent une sorte de partie autour
d'eux tous les grands partis aujourd'hui
assemblées sont des partis très récents
dans leur dénominations mais il n'y a
plus toutes ces espèces de sous-courant
des parties qui fait que leur candidat
reflète un petit peu d'histoire commune
non là c'est vraiment un homme qui doit
sauver tout le monde
et ce que je propose c'est plusieurs
options disons de la plus modeste à la
plus ambitieuse et la plus modeste c'est
juste mais c'est déjà ça ça paraît quand
même beaucoup de d'abolir par contre
référendum cette élection présidentielle
au suffrage universel et de revenir tout
simplement à la Constitution de 1958 où
le président est comme le dit De Gaulle
un arbitre et donc ne doit pas faire
partie du jeu politique et c'est un peu
un président à l'allemande l'Allemagne a
un président qui n'est pas censé
incarner la nation et on dit souvent que
les Français ont besoin d'un roi et
comme dit l'actuel président les
Français sont des royalistes régiss qui
veulent l'aimer pour le détester etc
mais regardons notre histoire qui a été
on a beaucoup sous-estimé la Troisième
République la Troisième République est
le régime le plus long de l'histoire de
France post révolutionnaire jusqu'à
maintenant c'est un régime où le
président de la République
personne ne le connaît c'est Paul
Deschanel qui est à moitié fou qui se
balade en pyjama sur les rails des
trains etc et c'est pas grave c'est pas
grave c'est pas grave parce que il est
là pour faire respecter l'équilibre des
institutions mais l'arbitre ne projette
pas ne projette pas du tout
identifié est-ce que pour la Troisième
République ils ont disait ah mais il
nous faut absolument une incarnation une
fois absolument un souverain pas du tout
et on avait fait les grandes lois
républicaines du début on a fait
traverser la Belle Époque professeur
économique traverser une guerre mondiale
sans recourir la dictature bref faut
réfléchir au régime qu'on a déjà eu et
qui ressemble un peu à la cinquième de
58 qui en fait du parlementariste
rationalisé en tout cas vous n'avez pas
peur de lancer un débat qui semble très
très loin aujourd'hui d'être vraiment
d'actualité et je vous remercie parce
que voilà ça ça nourrissent des bords on
pourrait même la voir de façon plus
longue avec un protecteur parce que
voilà il y en a il y en a beaucoup
contre un pour en finir avec l'élection
présidentielle c'est à l'observatoire
c'est passionnant c'est très très drôle
aussi parce que vous vous racontez sans
concession et de façon très très
humoristique la manière dont vous êtes
un peu en bourbé vous le dites dans
cette dans cette campagne présidentielle
faute de signature vous n'avez pas été
au bout je suis sûr que nos affranchis
vont vous intéressez vous restez avec
moi parce que on va les accueillir
maintenant pour leur partie prix ils
sont deux ce soir Pierre-Henri tavoyau
du collège de philosophie va nous parler
des mondiale de football qu'il conçoit
comme un théâtre universel absolument
sans équivalent et puis on va accueillir
un nouveau visage ce soir on est
d'ailleurs ravis de l'accueillir Nicole
Ferroni qui aura désormais régulièrement
une carte blanche sur cette nouvelle
Assemblée bonsoir à vous deux bonsoir
Myriam bienvenue Nicole et bonsoir
Pierre-Henri alors on parle de la Coupe
du monde ce soir avec vous évidemment
elle est lancée depuis deux jours on
croyait au boycott c'est plutôt raté
12,2 millions de téléspectateurs donc
bon c'est pas le chiffre exceptionnels
mais ça veut dire que le boycott le
match est plié il n'y a pas de bol Coop
boycott on le retrouvera peut-être que
lorsque l'équipe de France ce que je
n'espère pas sera éliminé peut-être le
débat reviendra mais en attendant pour
autant le débat entre sport et politique
lui n'est pas loin d'être terminé tous
ceux qui croyaient l'avoir co par une
formule magique il ne faut pas confondre
moral et politique faut pas mélanger
moral et politique et bien on était
rattrapés par l'actualité notamment par
les joueurs Iraniens qui d'une manière
incroyablement courageuse on refusé de
chanter le rythme alors évidemment à
Nîmes qui clament l'Iran éternel et même
la République islamique d'Iran éternel
on comprend que ces joueurs n'est pas
voulu le jouer parce que effectivement
jeunesse et massacrée la jeunesse de ce
pays par un régime autocratique les
joueurs Allemands voulaient en parler
aussi ce sont distingués oui c'est un
autre événement alors pas exactement du
même ordre avant leur match contre le
Japon les journals sont fait
photographier avec une main devant la
bouche signe d'une censure à leurs yeux
intolérables contre la FIFA qui leur
avait interdit de porter un brassard
arc-en-ciel où il était écrit on love
référence à la chanson Bob Marley qui
effectivement voulait dénoncer juste
titre d'ailleurs les la discrimination
LGBT Fab et raciste d'ailleurs de en
général et puis particulièrement au
Qatar puisque on le sait au Qatar
l'islam le
l'homosexualité toujours criminalisé et
vous ne souhaitez pas mettre ces deux
gestes sur le même plan pour vous ce
n'est pas comparable non oui la
comparaison est un peu cruelle parce que
d'un côté on a des joueurs Iraniens qui
sont d'un courage exceptionnel qui
prennent vraiment des risques pour eux
pour leur famille et qui lancent une
gifle un gouvernement autoritaire de
l'autre côté c'est quand même plutôt une
opération de com voire de marketing qui
va pas contre un régime mais plutôt dans
l'air du temps je ne doute pas de la
sincérité de des joueurs iraniens et de
la justesse de leur cause c'est pas du
tout le problème mais c'est le
communiqué la fédération qui m'a un peu
troublé dans ce communiqué il dit que ce
geste n'est pas politique
euh mais il a été fait au nom des droits
de l'homme qui sont non négociables
niches faire undelbach vous voyez
précise les choses non négociable
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
qu'on négocie pas or si les mots ont un
sens bah non négocié ça veut dire qu'on
joue pas tout simplement et donc le jeu
je trouve qu'il y a une sorte de un peu
d'hypocrisie et de volonté un peu de
tout mélanger vous voyez bien la
différence d'un côté un courage
extraordinaire de l'autre côté peu de
risques et la volonté de dire bah
écoutez on va jouer la Coupe du monde
quand même on va faire des leçons aux
méchants et en plus bah voilà on va
essayer de voir un peu sévère quand même
comme distribuer les bons points ça dit
une chose c'est une chose qui est assez
troublante c'est que le foot la Coupe du
monde reste un théâtre universel c'est
vrai que ici joue des tragédies des
comédies des pastilles des infromptus
des mauvaises pièces des bonnes pièces
mais ça reste un centre de référence et
dans ce monde dont on dit qu'il se
démondialise économiquement et
politiquement il y a quand même un
facteur d'unité dans cette Coupe du
monde et c'est une énigme parce que
franchement je suis de foot vous l'avez
compris mais ce foot qui est un sport de
tricheur de râleur qui est de mauvais
comédien qui se roule par terre en
hurlant pour la moindre petite poussette
ce sport aux règles bizarres dégoulinant
de fric pourquoi ce sport est le sport
pourquoi le foot voilà une vraie énigme
et j'ai un rêve si j'avais devant moi
chaque pire je lui poserai cette
question le grand dramaturge pourquoi ce
théâtre universel je sais pas ce qu'il
aurait répondu mais je suis certain
qu'il n'aurait pas dû écouter théâtre et
politique fait pas mélanger
à l'universalité du football merci
beaucoup pierre-aury tavoyé on voilà un
parti pris et qui m'offre une excellente
transition parce que vous vous nous
dites Nicole ce soir dans votre carte
blanche oui ben non regardez pas le foot
allez à l'Assemblée alors nouille en
fait déjà merci de m'accueillir sur SCP
non effectivement merci aussi peut-être
d'accueillir parmi vos téléspectateurs
des amateurs de foot qui sont peut-être
perdus et atterris sur LCP par hasard
parce que ils sont privés de matchs de
Ligue 1 du fait notamment qui est la
Coupe du monde en ce moment et donc qui
cherche peut-être une alternative de
sortie puisqu'ils peuvent pas aller au
stade et donc pour cette téléspectateur
là et pour peut-être pour vous tous j'ai
effectivement testé une sortie
culturelle et sportive cette semaine que
voici alors c'est écrit en petit ce
sport s'appelle la séance publique de
l'Assemblée nationale alors qu'est-ce
que c'est comme sport c'est à mi-chemin
entre du football et du Krav Maga sauf
que au lieu comment dire au lieu que ce
soit des footballeurs qui viennent en
fait dans le stade afin de disputer des
matchs et bien ce sont l'ensemble des
députés du territoire qui viennent à
l'hémicycle afin de disputer des textes
comme par exemple l'IVG dans la
Constitution alors vous avez posé la
question Nicole est-ce qu'il y a des
avantages pour les supporters de foot à
venir à l'Assemblée nationale plutôt que
au stade et ben la réponse est oui bien
sûr déjà le prix le prix d'entrée du
billet puisque c'est gratuit pour tous
les Français d'aller à l'Assemblée
nationale il suffit d'aller sur le site
de l'Assemblée nationale vous remplissez
un petit formulaire vous
[Rires]
n'est donc pas le droit de faire ni de
haut là ni de banderole évidemment pas
sur le thé l'arbitre ni sa femme et pas
le droit de chanter et là j'ai trouvé ça
un peu dommage parce que moi je m'étais
dit ah oui le fameux
stade qui va amander voilà il va non
vous n'avez pas le droit de faire ça
parce que on a pas le droit de montrer
un soutien ouvert à son équipe en même
temps
c'est pas très grave parce que pour être
honnête même si vous aviez ce droit là
et ben c'est très compliqué parce que
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué qu'au foot
en fait à l'Assemblée nationale parce
que le but c'est pas de faire rentrer
juste un ballon dans les cages mais de
faire entrer des mots dans les textes de
loi et comme chaque député veut pouvoir
faire rentrer des mots en fait c'est
comme si tous les ballons partaient en
même temps donc c'est très très dur à
suivre mais en même temps ce qui était
pas le plus dur pour moi c'était pas ça
c'était plus que Ben le match peut être
annulé à la dernière minute par 49 fois
via la première ministre et en fait
alors le 49-3 pour ceux qui savent pas
mais c'est c'est comme si la FIFA en
fait elle décidait le score du match
avant même qu'il était joué du coup je
me disais c'est un peu bête d'avoir
sélectionné des joueurs cet été pour pas
les voir jouer voilà 49-3 pire que la
FIFA c'est ça l'amour
Gaspard Kenny vous auriez aimé député
après après ce qu'on apprend sur la vie
à l'Assemblée non pas trop mais j'admire
le fait que effectivement le débat
politique est un jeu et David grever qui
est notre Pollock que j'aime beaucoup
explique que c'est le jeu qui nous rend
humain et c'est pour ça que quand on
fait de la politique on joue et que donc
s'il y a toutes ces joute ces
exagérations à l'Assemblée c'est
précisément parce que c'est une
assemblée d'humains qui fait l'essence
de la politique et c'est d'ailleurs pour
revenir je retourne sur mes pattes de
notre premier sujet tout ce que
détestait de Gaulle dans le
parlementarisme c'était le côté ludique
et en fait le côté ludique et le côté le
plus important pour votre humanité on
reviendrait quand même j'espère
évidemment il y a beaucoup de matchs
encore en plus me voilà rassuré merci
Pierre-Henri tavoyau merci à vous de
nous avoir suivis à demain même lieu
même heure c'est Jean-Pierre Garcia qui
prend la main avec une belle soirée
documentaire en perspective très belle
soirée sur scène
[Musique]